on the mountain for the nationals sean
nolan his fourth start as a nat third
against the met
there's one on the ground to garcia's
right
throw on the run
quickly
two outs here in the first
seventh start for rich hill his last
start as gary mentioned very good couple
of runs eight k's but it was a loss to
the nats
lane thomas strokes one into left field
this guy cannot stop hitting
came into tonight batting 314 as a
national
there's a lead off knock here in the
first
check this box quickly there goes the no
lane thomas with another knock
stay hot lane stay in your lane lane
and he drives this one toward the gap in
right center nimmo goes back and makes
the catch all the way to second was
thomas i don't know if he retouched or
not he gets back to first they're going
to appeal at second base he went past
the bag and i don't know if he touched
it coming back
absolutely did not absolutely oh youtube
that's a double play and there are two
out
if you go past the bag you have got to
retouch on your way back to first thomas
did not and he has doubled up well there
you go you made the turn now you got to
touch it
that's just ignorance the rules isn't it
or is it is it just getting you know
excited in the moment
nervous about getting back i think
that's part of it um it happens though
once or twice a year we see it
21st game is admit
loop the other way that's going to fall
in
fair base it javi baez around first on
his way to second soto's throw not in
time a bloop double for baez and the
mets have their first hit of the night
got tied up up and in here
beat inside but he's so strong
he's able to flare it out there
head first
oh the knees
probably just scraped it all over the
bag and so the mets with their first
base runner and michael conforto comes
up
lined off the pitcher and nolan is hurt
baez will score conforta with a base hit
and now the concern for sean nolan
conforto banked it right off nolan and
into center field and fortunately he is
up on his feet let's see
got him pretty square actually looking
at the replay
look at the knuckle ball
got him in the throwing room i don't
know that's going to tighten up
he might be able to get through this
ending but when he sits around for a
minute that's going to get tight
he tells davey and paul that he's
okay after throwing a couple warm-up
tosses but that can't feel good and had
to be incredibly scary
and he drills this one down the left
field line that's a base in it'll go to
the corner conforto on his way to third
into second base with a double his
pillar he continues to strafe nolan and
the mets with three straight hits so
here's chance cisco with two in scoring
position and just one out
comes the payoff pitch
swing and a miss
86 on that cutter
[Applause]
sean nolan manipulating the velocity of
that pitch over the course of this ab a
huge strikeout 77 92 86 different angles
big second out here and now you got to
go right after rich hill is he going to
bunt here with two strikes
kind of slaps at that one
carter kibum has the third half so sean
nolan allows a run
takes a comebacker off his throwing
shoulder but gets out of further trouble
hesitation by nolan and nimmo takes
inside ball four and the mets have a one
out base runner
first walk given up by nolan
so two out now alonso
along the right field line a long run
for soto and toward the line he won't
get there it drops a base hit nemo
around third he's gonna score alonzo all
the way to third with a triple and the
mets lead it to nothing
tough play for soto here just misses it
you almost want to think he almost got
it that maybe you want to pull up and
that's a tough play luis garcia leading
off the home half of the third
turns on this breaking ball that's a
fair ball
garcia smokes one into the right field
corner
and in five career at bats against rich
hill he now has two doubles
see him clear the hips create a lot of
room in there to hit the inside pitch it
just lands fair so a lead off double for
garcia
garcia got a huge jump but he went too
soon
another base running mistake by the
nationals
and vr puts on the tag
and now nimbo is first with one out for
francisco lindor
this one's fair and far out to left
center lane thomas after it a slide and
he's got it
covered a ton of ground to get over
there
went into a slide
and picked it just off the turf for out
number two what a play by lane thomas
backhand grab off the grass look how far
he's going he's in right center field
and he runs all the way to left center
field to make this play remember josh
bell was toward the line he knows he's
got to cover the left center field gap
when he started in right center
and then he makes an amazing throw all
the way to first base on a couple of
hops to try to get the double play what
a play by lane thomas
he's got a whole bunch of bag of tricks
he does doesn't he it's fun to watch
one two coming to bell
and news at the sidearm gets the ground
ball lindora goes to baez side retired
six scoreless innings for rich hill
tonight never better as a match here's
juan soto to lead it off
first pitch swinging fly ball left field
towards the line
and it's gone
juan soto sees one pitch and sends it
out of the yard and the nationals are on
the board here in the bottom of the nine
fastball away see you later two to one
didn't even really get it but edwin diaz
supplied the power juan soto touches it
with the barrel we got a one run game
hold on
now ryan zimmerman who's gone over three
tonight
there we go
four pitch walk
the tying run is a board here in the
bottom of the ninth
as the rookie catcher riley adams will
come up
stevenson's off adams to right center
it falls in front of a diving nemo
stevenson is being waved home by bob
headley
the throw to the plates a collision
stevenson taps the plate and the game is
tied riley adams to third
and then that's it plated two so far in
the bottom of the night via's made it
super close at home and they might have
had him if he hangs on to it here but
that's just a natural collision you
don't see contact at home plate anymore
that that's just so refreshing that
everybody's okay you're hoping
well chance cisco has
come out of this game oh yeah he took
maybe right on the head the concussion
so here's alonzo who's one for four
tonight had the fly ball triple to
driving a run in the third that's the
last run the mets scored and lonzo lines
one into center field for a base hit
lindor around third he'll come in to
score he and alonzo down in the count
dumps one into right center and the mets
go back in front three to two
one two to pilar
and he lines one base hit down the left
field line that'll bring in alonzo
digging for third is conforto he's gonna
be waved home the relay by escobar to
the plate not in time all the way to
third goes pillar
kevin pillar comes through again
a two-run double to put the mets up five
to two in the tenth
grab ball up the middle base head fourth
hit of the night for vr that brings in
pilar it's booted in right field by soto
davis will stop at third vr all the way
to second and the mets tack on it's now
six to two
ground ball vr has got it
the throw across the diamond stretched
by alonso he got him and the ball game
is over